it was just an impromptu moment that
just
i mean i think i've done it a lot on
stage and then decided to do it there
but it became something new you
surprised that i became a meme
i mean you know what it assists me with
an opportunity to do it again let's see
if we can make this involved you ready
[Music]
you're back in vegas with a brand new
residency yeah i mean why did you want
to come back to vegas what was it i was
like okay let me try to be a little bit
more theatrical let me bring a little
bit of broadway into this because i've
done that as well yes you know give
people a little bit of the backstory of
some of the songs and
kind of allow them to be immersed in my
world for two seconds
usher my way is running through october
at park mgm's dolby live this is his
second sin city residency and the 43
year old is showing off skills on skates
it's intended to inspire you to get out
there and get on skates we were just
talking about he's like i ain't great on
them i can't do it but hopefully you're
inspired and hopefully you'll make your
way to new york and go to flippers that
part
yeah this year has been full of you know
introducing new things we opened up a
skating rink at rockefeller center
flippers which is a historical story and
an immersive experience in itself and
then just skating and just you know
showing people what i love to do when
i'm not singing
i feel like routine have you always been
that good on skates
i uh i got better you did so you did
practice and now i'm forced to be even
better because now i got the world you
know counting on me to never slip right
but we do you know you're gonna have
those moments but hopefully not on stage
i can't believe it's 25 years since my
way
would you say to that young man starting
out in the music industry i would say be
okay
with
the hard times as much as you can
celebrate the good times
because there is a silver lining always
and it comes by way of you acknowledging
that you are growing yes that you are
trying to
stay connected in the moment but with
the vision of being able to go forward
and you're going to help a lot of people
you have your eighth studio album coming
out soon uh what do you want your fans
to know about this next era of usher
more than anything i try my hardest to
be as honest open vulnerable direct with
my audience and hopefully a continuous
celebration to the story that we've been
building throughout all of these years
is there someone still on that dream
list of collaborations for you i love
some of the new artists that are out
here
and i uh recognize uh the legendary
artists who have been
so you never know with me man i love
what i see people like um lady gaga do
you know when she did something with
tony bennett i thought that was really
good stage two on this stage in this
house right
uh and then you know just new ideas with
new artists
um i think it's important to continue to
stay connected and again uh be
collaborative because you never know
where the next idea is gonna come from
[Music]